anything stand out in sports right now
how are you thinking about sports
uh what what are we gonna see from when
is it coming back what what's what's
some of your hot takes and
understandings
you know there's some some people out
there whether it's business or
sports teams that that love debt are
are uh in those teams uh could be in
some trouble
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy what blows me away about you
is
not only are you an actual hall of fame
athlete which is
such rare fight air but as i've gotten
to know you over the last three or four
years
your ambition and entrepreneurial savvy
is gonna put you eventually in the
entrepreneurial hall of fame i i don't
like co-signing people because i don't
like being wrong but i've been blown
away by
your tenacity and humility coming off
the platform you've come from
and jumping in right off the bat how
what are you leaning into
as an entrepreneur during this period
that we're all dealing with
what is kind of what's manifested in
these last 75 days from a personality
tree
yeah look gary thank you for welcoming
uh happy to be here
one of the things that i'm looking at
since we have a this will be a sprint
not a marathon
uh i'll talk in small bites but the
bottom line is joe torre
um my new york yankee manager taught me
alex when you have a rain delay those
that go in the back room and eat burgers
and pizzas and fries
end up like zeros you stay prepared keep
your
jersey on get on the bike stay warm keep
your mind in the game
and then when you go out there you're
going to close like a champion i am
looking
at this covet 19 as our rain delay the
game's not over
we will continue and whoever is best
prepped
in this time will win later so i'm
preparing for later
and i'm positioning my company for to be
in a better position
than we were before how do you translate
that energy as somebody who's lived it
is in that mindset
to your direct reports and the
individuals in your ecosystem
who let's just shoot it straight may not
have the financial
you know stability that you have you
know to invest
mentally in the long term how do you
impose that on somebody who might be
making you know 70k a year
or 200k a year but has expenses like
that's been a big thought of mine have
you been thinking about that
well i've done two things and we have
teams all over the place we have a big
team in new york big team in la and
obviously here in
south florida we have not cut one person
we haven't cut one percent of one salary
and the reason why uh even though
uh it's justified in this moment to do
that because obviously the income and
the revenue is not the same
i wanted to make sure that at the
darkest moment uh a-rock corps
shined and we were there for them and
that's one of the great advantages i i
believe in working in a company like
ours we really
think about our team first and uh
so that's one number two my west coast
team uh
they go to they go to sleep to my emails
they wake up to my emails and and
i'm up before them in the west coast and
i'm usually uh sleep uh
after them so it's it's it's it's being
active is never sleeping and is really
just being all in be leaning into it
what have you observed from others who
what who
or what corp what organization
government
business human being give me a hot take
on two to four
you know one three things that have
stood out for you things you've seen out
in the zeitgeist
from other leaders anything okay yeah
anheuser-busch is one uh because they're
a big conglomerate right like like
google or disney or
you know abc their abi and uh they're
gritty
uh they they really really care about uh
the bottom line uh they don't turn the
ball over like we say in sports
they really stay in their lane they
think outside the box
and and those are things with my
partnership with presidente that i've
really enjoyed watching them
was that a pleasant surprise for you
right you're doing this big partnership
with them on this beer
which i'm fired up about and and uh
marcel who's coming on next we're always
open to work on this brand i know we
work with budweiser and others but we'll
talk about that next but
was that a like you know obviously you
know you know marcel's in the waiting
room he's coming on next so
you need to be politically correct i
respect that and i mean this because i
want this to be a transparent day
but was it nice to see such a big
company and listen i want everybody
who's watching
abi this is a common knowledge like
they're a big player in china they got
hit there early first
it's not like they're unbelievable you
know like these are real business
challenges
and yet still showing you humanity even
though when
they're having business channels for you
did that kind of catch you off guard
were you just pleasantly surprised did
you expect that because you like the way
you've been onboarding with them what
was
what happened there well usually i i
just loved how
how quickly they're able to move i mean
usually you don't see a cruise ship
move like a speed boat and that's
exactly what they did
when we announced uh in in houston
uh our partnership jennifer and i came
on the stage there was about three
uh 3 000 or so customers of abi
and literally i got an email four days
later they're saying hey
we're going to do we've decided to do a
super bowl commercial and i said well
how can that be the super bowl is like
in 10 days
and they said we're doing it it went and
it was a huge success and
uh really really excited to see a
company that big be that nimble
alex what um what about what's going on
in the sports business world obviously
we've got a lot of cmos on the back so i
want to fill out this program
anything stand out in sports right now
how are you thinking about sports
uh what what are we gonna see from when
is it coming back what what's what's
some of your hot takes and
understandings
you know there there's some some people
out there whether it's business or
sports teams that that love debt or
are in those teams uh could be in some
trouble
because the loss of revenues are going
to be massive more than people can even
imagine
and they'll trickle down to 21 and 22.
um
what's interesting is some businesses
like michael rupino
over at um live nation one of the best
ceos around
uh more than 90 percent of the people
have not
wanted a refund so that's great news for
live nation
great wow is that the number that's
being thrown around
90 have kept and which tells you people
love live experiences they're gonna feel
good
this is their comfort food oh they can't
wait they're not giving up that ticket
to
bon jovi or beyonce or jay-z or j-lo
whoever it is
that number gary stood out to me 90 kept
their tickets impressive
social tick tock instagram
linkedin youtube what has the uh the
a-rod and family clan
you as an individual as a content
creator i've been seeing some pretty
epic
tick tocks from you and jen and the fam
like what what
what's your observations there anything
catching your mind anything you're
personally hot on
or people around you yeah some really
embarrassing ones too
on the front we've had a lot of fun and
gotten really creative here
uh which is hard for me but we continue
one of the things i've learned from you
is using every platform don't just be
biased to one
use each platform i got to get better at
using each platform a little bit
differently
it's hard but nadeem who loves you he's
he's he's
always around me and and he does a great
job with jason and ashley in our digital
team
but once talking to you and andrea one
of the things that i did even with reid
is
i triple down on my team when i first
met you
i had zero now we have seven in our team
and then jennifer's getting into it too
and her content is getting better
she's a content machine so we we're
being aggressive we're
still trying to be sensitive to the
times but somehow bringing value to
those people at home because right now
is a time where champions are built
segwaying a little bit to give you a
little bit of the floor what's uh
what are you excited about what do you
what are you hoping
in the next six months to a year the
world knows
about you or what you're up to you know
you've got a real
vast amount of people watching this
right now like what are you what are you
looking for them to know about
the masses well i mean i think you know
we have um
we do two things at art corp we do a
real estate which we're fully integrated
we've been doing it for 20 years we have
around 8 000 apartments
all over the southeast uh and we've done
really really good things there
uh on the pe and venture side we're
owners of about 20 to 25
companies and it's interesting you know
they've been kind of broken into thirds
a third are doing really bad a third are
kind of floating and a third have never
done better
and uh it's just been really interesting
to work with our founders
our boards and really really be involved
one of the most
exciting partnerships that i've ever
done and probably uh
you can't say that about your kids but
presidente is probably number one
because it's from dominican republic it
was founded in 1935
and it's such an organic marriage the
day i signed you called me you
congratulated me right away
this is a winner how can i help i'm a
big fan when things are just
blatantly obvious right and so to me i
think a lot of people do brand deals
and partnerships and business deals
where they're just chasing money
and and the and that deal given i mean
yeah that was literally one of my
favorites obviously i knew both parties
didn't know about the deal but
knew both parties so it just it just
made it i made a ton of ton of ton of
sense
um alex what about what about the way
you're thinking about
influencer uh uh collaborations one of
the things that i thought
was super interesting about you early on
was when you kind of made this switch
to this you know you reached out to me i
watched you do other things with others
like how do you think about one thing
i'm completely fascinated with right now
i saw spencer
x do something with alicia keys spencer
x for everybody doesn't know is a tick
tock influencer who's one of the top 10
on the platform though i know 98 of
people when i just said that don't know
who that is
i think some of the i think you're
extremely savvy with attention and
culture
you know you're busy back to content
creation but how much do you
you did the bar stool podcast jb right i
i think you've been
very clever on collabs like a music
artist that's trying to get into other
genres
has it been on purposes have you seen
that is that something you want to do
more of
where do you sit with thoughtful
collaborations where
where audience exchange is happening
yeah i mean whether it's charlie from
tick tock or whether it's ed milette
or is you and i doing something but it's
really tapping into
a different set of people that are not
in my everyday life i mean i'm in
baseball 24 7.
so the 58 59 year old white male
is it knows who you are well or hey and
and that fan is gonna
follow me to cnbc and again uh
very one percent so when when i thought
about barstool
i thought about my daughter's generation
uh the college generation
when i walked in colleges today they'll
tell me oh my god the kobe bryant
podcast
the garyvee podcast uh
they don't tell me about the world
series they don't tell me about home
runs they know me as a business person
entrepreneur who is talking to them and
is educating them with some good nuggets
through their podcast it's a powerful
thing
final question maybe i'll get one more
but but if i don't get this one in i'm
going to be devastated
alex i believe that your sp
rookie card perfectly graded is one of
the most
underpriced assets in the world right
now
much like real estate sports cards have
been grossly underpriced you know i've
been yelling about it for a year now
it's going mainstream the journal the
atlantic
everyone's writing about it yes or no
are you planning on buying every one of
your own rookie cards because it might
be a
bigger financial win than even all these
incredible business
ventures you're in i would love to buy
it and if you can broker that
i'm on it together i'm on i'm on it bro
i'm telling you it's super
underpriced i mean i i view you winning
culture over the next 50 years and i
think it's just gonna keep going up so
you need to get on that any parting
shots since i think i got one more
minute yeah and i just want to say thank
you uh for having me i just want to
encourage everybody out there
um these are tough times no question
about it but just like i would tell my
yankee teammates
stay ready stay prepared stay physically
fit
and when in doubt attack what's your
twitter handle because i see everybody
um
marketing for the now i see all of you
i'm sharing it we're gonna blow up
twitter in these two hours
as as it should be hey rod thank you so
much brother stay healthy say hi to jen
i'll talk to you soon you've got it
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out